joining me now ian pryor executive
director of the parent group fight for
schools and a father of two school-aged
children he previously worked in the
trump administration's doj ian great to
have you on you know it's kind of you
listen to mike's report there and the
country for the most part is trying to
stay open but a lot of these school
districts a lot of these teachers unions
are pushing for closure temporary
closure are you surprised there hasn't
been more pushback against them
well you know if they decide to do that
in in various counties and districts
throughout the country i mean there is
going to be pushback this would be the
third straight year where you have some
kind of remote learning and let's be
clear this isn't remote learning because
there's no learning being done you know
children need to be in schools they need
to be socializing with other students
they need to be in the classroom it's
tough enough when they have masks but at
least they're in a physical space where
they can learn
if we start going back to virtual
learning i mean parents all over the
country are going to be you know in such
a difficult position because of course
they have to work as well so now they
have to figure out a way to balance work
and have their children at home in this
virtual setup that quite frankly stunts
their growth and development it amazes
me that you know you have some of these
teachers unions saying that they don't
want to teach these healthy kids and
then you have the cdc wanting kids back
in school saying even if you tested
positive after five days without a
negative test you need to be back in
school
yeah i mean that's right look the way it
all works you go on sundays you watch
the nfl you've got players you've got 60
70 000 people in there they're going to
figure it out why are they going to
figure it out because if you don't sell
tickets you don't make money but when
you're looking at schools you know look
the teachers are going to get their
teachers unions are going to get their
dues from the teachers regardless of
whether schools are open or not counties
and districts are going to get their
taxpayer dollars regardless of whether
schools are open or not so there's no
incentive for them to keep school open
and look there's always going to be
another variant right whether it's
omicron now or something next year you
know if we don't work our way through
this in an organized fashion you know
we're looking at a lost generation of
kids that quite frankly weren't able to
learn when they were in their
development stages you heard some of
these teachers saying well we just want
you know enough adults in the school to
make sure these kids are safe i want to
read to you the united federation of
teacher statement it says quoting here
teachers are prepared to do their jobs
starting january 3rd the real issue is
whether the city can do its job ensuring
that new testing initiatives are
available in every school and an
improved situation room is actually in
place by next week and that's the old
framing coming back in here ian right oh
the teachers are ready to go back it's
up to the cities and the country to put
these schools back in in a in a way that
we feel safe going back into them
that's right i mean they're always going
to be passing the buck just like we saw
in 20 2020 and 2021 but you know we're
going into another election year in 2022
and you can start to see mayor de blasio
shifting his messaging a little bit and
saying no schools need to be open you're
starting to see that from the cdc which
are not who you're not seeing it from is
the teachers unions and the teachers
unions are going to keep pushing this
and quite frankly randy weingarten the
aft nea i mean they are responsible for
what has happened to our schools over
the past several years and you know
people are going to be looking at them
and looking at their influence in 2022
and beyond in 2024 and they're the ones
that people are going to point to and
say you're the reason why our kids
weren't able to be in school you talk
about their influence but their
influence has become extraordinarily
powerful during this pandemic and so
that is part and parcel of a bigger
problem ian pryor it's great to have you
on hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else